74 years ago hundreds of caribbean
migrants climbed aboard the empire wind
rush ready to start their new lives in
britain it was just after the second
world war and the country needed help so
people like alfred who had already
served in the raf took up their
invitations
i was here before
i went home and i first think i said
it's mama when i went to home i'm going
back
with no time let me help chase i told
her i was going back and
i had no reasons to come back
and here i am still here
enjoying it
tomorrow this year's windrush day he
joined this tour returning to where it
all began
here at tilbury darks is where the
empire wind rush first arrived 74 years
ago today
aboard where hundreds of migrants from
across the caribbean who'd left friends
families and their homes behind to come
and help rebuild britain
but even though it was in july it was
cold it was windy and it was very
different for what most of them had been
used to
but even though they were invited when
they arrived they weren't welcomed like
this
many experience racism discrimination
and 70 years later deportations
this is not for black people only it is
for the whole
of britain
to understand
to learn
something of the history of why we're
here how we came to be here
today a brand new statue was unveiled at
waterloo station
people like baroness benjamin who
arrived in london from trinidad in 1960
4 000 miles across the atlantic ocean we
landed at southampton docks and we got
onto that train from southampton to
waterloo station and there i am
standing on platform 19 waterloo station
very close to here with my suitcase with
my grip so this this monument represents
my story
a story not just of that generation but
for the direct descendants of all of
those who settled raised families and
redefined what it meant to be british
shimon freeman powell sky news